[Musique]
ouais c'est bien philippe elain
bonsoir à tous et à toutes je m'appelle
angelo foley et bas ce soir je vais vous
parler des peurs c'est un sujet pour moi
qui me suit depuis pas mal d'années
maintenant
d'ailleurs là j'ai peur de vous parler
j'ai peur de dire de la merde j'ai peur
d'avoir des trous de mémoire j'ai peur
de pas être à la hauteur du grand ted
j'ai peur de vous ennuyer puisque ça
fait quand même un petit moment où vous
nous écoutez
et voilà la chaire
de vous le dire là ça va mieux déjà
merci
[Applaudissements]
merci sécu
est en fait je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué mais je ne parle pas de
n'importe quelle peur là je parle pas
par exemple de la peur
de se retrouver en plein milieu de la
jungle face à un tigre à parlant jumanji
ça arrive pas à beaucoup de personnes
je parle pas de la peur par exemple de
traverser et de manquer de se faire
renverser par un camion je parle pas de
la peur non plus
de l'effondrement je parle pas de la
peur du corps d'un virus je parle pas de
la peur de sauter en parachute
vous avez remarqué mais je toutes les
peurs dont je parle en fait
ont un point commun est en fait là par
exemple je parle de la peur de parler en
public je parle de la peur de dire ce
qu'on pense vraiment un repas de famille
je parle de la peur de demander une
augmentation à son boss ou à sa bosse je
parle de la peur de dire à quelqu'un
qu'il ou elle nous plaît je parle de la
peur d'être jugés de lancer un projet
qui nous tient à coeur depuis longtemps
la peur d'être abandonné la peur d'être
rejetés a perdu 4 l auteur la peur d'en
faire trop ou ne pas en faire assez
bref je parle de toutes les peurs
finalement qu'on ressent alors qu'on
n'est pas vraiment en danger de mort
et
le point commun que j'ai observée parmi
toutes ces peurs finalement c'était la
relation à l'autre
alors sartre à l'époque nous disait déjà
l'enfer c'est les autres je pense que
pour lui l'enfer c'était surtout son
strabisme
mais la ga part
je sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais
il ya quelques choses fondamentalement
qui nous est insupportable nous les
humains c'est de ne pas avoir le
sentiment d'exister dans le regard de
l'autre
c'est insupportable c'est un petit peu
comme si on était des morts vivants en
fait ce que j'ai en train de vous dire
c'est que si on avait pas de relation on
n'aurait pas le sentiment d'exister
et
le point commun finalement de tout ça
c'est la relation à l'autre le regard de
l'autre et donc pour nous les humains
avoir le sentiment d'exister dans le
regard de l'autre eh ben la première
chose qu'on cherche à faire c'est à
chercher à devenir quelqu'un pour
quelqu'un d'autre
personnellement moi ça fait plus de
trente ans que j'essaie de devenir
quelqu'un
j'ai écumé déjà pas mal de stratégie
pour obtenir un maximum de like un
maximum d'attention et je vais vous
donner un petit peu quelques exemples de
mon cv dans le désordre alors par
exemple à une époque j'ai fait chanteur
de rock mélancolique incompris
donc là on était plutôt sur cheveux
longs et gras
tatouages piercings jean troué
un peu comme aujourd'hui quoi en fait
qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai fait mais
que branché parisien qui bosse dans la
com donc là faut imaginer un univers
plutôt de pubard agence de pub
il y avait évidemment des jeux vidéo
pendant nos pauses
j'étais plutôt stan smith j'avais des
lunettes carrées noir et puis bah
évidemment il y avait des compètes des
soirées du champagne
j'ai fait gendre idéal aussi
alors là évidemment j'étais propriétaire
d'un appartement
il y avait plutôt de la déco scandinave
je faisais des repas fusion japonaise
évidemment j'avais des traits d'humour
bien placé avec mes beaux-parents de
l'époque
j'ai même voilà fait des demandes en
mariage au pluriel
toi aussi tu es tu arrivé
force
après j'ai fait quoi j'ai fait sportif
de haut niveau fin de carrière plus tôt
donc là on était plutôt sur les jus
pressée à froid qui avait remplacé le
champagne du pub art
qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai fait
évidemment cinq entraînements par
semaine des repas très spécifiques et
puis évidemment j'avais tout le matos le
plus cher du marché dont je me servais
pas trop
j'ai fait maître spirituel gourou et
veiller aussi
donc là on est plutôt au niveau
capillaire sur cheveux rasés la tenue
c'était plutôt dépouillé pas jusqu'aux
saroual faut pas déconner
évidemment je faisais des retraites la
méditation yoga
yoga évidemment je buvais du yogi tea et
donc j'avais des phrases toutes faites
dans ma tête et je faisais un peu de
sénevé histoire d'entretenir un peu la
bienveillance
voilà et puis
un mets préféré c'est le hashtag enfants
abandonnés qui s'est fait tout seul
voilà suis là je le sors tu es un petit
peu quand j'étais en galère
s'est fait tout seul vous voyez en fait
au niveau cv chez plutôt assez complet
pas mal d'expérience en termes de
chercher à devenir quelqu'un pour pour
quelqu'un d'autre est en fait ce que
j'ai observé
en premier c'est que pour chercher à
devenir quelqu'un pour quelqu'un d'autre
le premier truc qu'on fait c'est qu'on
se comparer donc on cherche à devenir
quelqu'un par rapport aux autres
donc cherché à devenir quelqu'un par
rapport aux autres c'est ce qu'ont
paraît donc sait se distinguer des 7 ou
8 milliards d'individus sait se
différencier
c'est chercher à être original chercher
à être unique
évidemment c'est nourrir une certaine
image de soi
et puis ben c'est aussi tenter d'obtenir
un maximum d'attention et pourquoi pas à
terme même d'être aimé
et donc pour se comparer nous les
humains ce qu'on fait très simplement je
sais pas comment on l'a appris mais on
l'a appris c'est que en fait on se
compare en se mettant soit au dessus
soit en dessous et donc du coup quand on
se met au dessus
on utilise plutôt l'orgueil qui est
plutôt quelque chose de positif
puisqu'en fait on va se décrire comme
quelqu'un avec des notions positives
comme la domination le pouvoir la
réussite la force ou la toute puissance
et quand on va plutôt se comparer en
négatif c'est-à-dire du coup utilisez
plutôt la dévalorisation et ben on va
chercher à exister plus tôt à travers la
soumission à travers le retrait à
travers les chèques
à travers la leur puissance la
victimisation et je crois que nous les
êtres humains si on est prêt à autant
d'orgueil et de dévalorisation pour
avoir de la tension c'est parce qu'au
fond chercher à devenir quelqu'un pour
quelqu'un d'autre c'est un petit peu
notre réponse à notre peur de n'être
personne pour l'autre
en fait on mesure notre sentiment
d'exister grâce à l'attention que les
autres nous porte que ce soit en positif
ou en négatif est donc en fait on
pourrait considérer que un like égale
une unité d'attention
donc le nous on a un besoin viscéral les
êtres humains d'exister dans le regard
de l'autre pour avoir nous même le
sentiment d'être quelqu'un mais pas
uniquement si on observe par exemple sur
le règne animal eh ben on se rend compte
que l'être humain est assez vulnérable
voire très vulnérable c'est à dire qu'il
n'est pas en capacité de survivre seule
à son environnement sans défense et donc
nous évidemment par orgueil on s'est mis
tout temps les gèle les yeux des animaux
mais en réalité si on regarde bien on
n'a pas grand chose on n'a pas de dents
ou de griffes acérées ont fait pas un
poids ou une taille démesurée on sait
pas vraiment bien nager on n'a pas de
nageoires on n'a pas d'elle on n'a pas
de vision nocturne on n'a pas de vision
à longue distance on n'a pas de force ou
de puissance spécifique on n'a pas grand
chose et donc pour survivre à notre
environnement seul et parce qu'on fait
c'est qu'on s'aimait à plusieurs et pour
s'y mettre à plusieurs nous créons des
relations
puis nous créons des groupes des
familles des communautés des sociétés et
nourrit notre sentiment d'appartenance
et donc en fait comme on le commence met
en relation si vous voulez c'est comme
si on utilisait l'image le soir c'est
cette fameuse image qu'on a comme une
interface des changes entre nous les
humains et on passe par l'image que l'on
donne à regarder à l'autre pour pouvoir
échanger communiquer et du coup sûr
vivre tous ensemble
ça
le problème de l'image de soi c'est que
c'est une image qui est fixe
c'est un peu comme un costume qui ferait
de nous une caricature de nous mêmes
c'est un petit peu comme si on était en
devenait un personnage qui finalement se
comporterait dans la vie de tous les
jours comme sur scène en fait on se fige
comme une statue
est en fait ce qui est dingue c'est que
ce qui un jour à une période de notre
vie nous a aidé à survivre
au fur et à mesure ça devient une sorte
de prison
de laquelle on devient à la fois le
gardien et le détenu et c'est
complètement paradoxal
ce processus là on l'appelle
l'identification alors vous entendrez
peut-être ce mot ego
et donc moi j'appelle ça
l'identification est donc en fait
l'identification c'est quoi c'est ce que
j'aime ce que je fais ce que je vis
deviens avec le temps ce que je suis et
ce par quoi je me définis donc on peut
s'identifier à tous on peut s'identifier
a évidemment son apparence son physique
son corps son métier ses activités son
argent ses habitations ses possessions
son nom de famille sa place dans la
famille
on peut s'identifier à nouveau à nos
croyances on peut s'identifier à nos
émotions à nos peurs évidemment un autre
hommage à nos blessures on peut
s'identifier à tous en fait on a un truc
chez nous qui fait qu' on arrive à
transformer ce qu'on a en ce qu'on est
et donc moi j'ai un prénom j'ai une
activité j'ai un métier j'ai des
souvenirs j'ai des émotions et au fur et
à mesure ce que j'ai devient ce que je
suis très simples comme exemple si vous
demandez à quelqu'un tu fais quoi dans
la vie le premier truc qui vous répond
c'est je suis médecin je suis artiste je
suis professeur je suis artisan est donc
en fait ce que j'ai devient ce que je
suis
et la difficulté par rapport à par
rapport à cette identification c'est que
au bout d'un moment
on s'enferme dedans
on s'enferme dans notre identité on
s'enferme dans l'image qu'on a de soi et
qu'on donne à regarder à l'autre en fait
c'est dans cette identité à un moment
donné ça devient tellement quelque chose
d paix et de solides parce qu'on a
appris à l'entretenir
que ça finit par devenir ça finit par
former une sorte d'armure qui nous donne
l'impression d'être protégés de
l'extérieur et en même temps qui nous
séparent les uns des autres parce que
plus les armures et pèse pas plus on est
loin les uns des autres et plus j'ai
enfin - je vois quelque part qui sont
les autres et qui se dit autour de moi
donc en fait on s'enferme dans une sorte
de forteresse et cette identité devient
une forteresse de laquelle il est très
difficile de sortir et donc je problème
c'est que le moment où on s'en rend
compte qu'on était enfermée c'est au
moment où ça craque
c'est au moment où ça s'effondre c'est
au moment où ça marche plus
alors par exemple c'est au moment où
vous avez tout donné à une société pour
prouver pendant 30 ans qui vous étiez
pour prouver vous étiez compétents que
vous étiez capables et que vous finissez
en burn out
ça s'effondre au moment où vous avez une
carrière artistique ça a bien marché et
puis vous êtes identifié à cette artiste
que vous étiez et puis à un moment donné
ça se finit vous allez plus que vous
êtes vous partez en dépression
ça arrive au moment où ben vous tenter
par exemple de sauver tout le monde
autour de vous et que en fait face à la
mort de vos proches vous retrouvé
impuissant
moi dans mon cv par exemple tout s'est
effondré pour ça que je vous en parle
c'est parce que si je vous donne
quelques exemples
bah quand j'étais dans l' agence de pub
et que j'étais je faisais le pubard oui
j'ai gagné quelques compétitions c'était
sympa j'avais des idées etc mais au fur
et à mesure je me suis rendu compte que
mes slogan c'était du vent
quand par exemple
je faisais le gendre idéal
j'ai annulé de mariage
toujours au pluriel
quand je faisais le sportif de haut
niveau bas j'ai poussé le bouchon
tellement loin je me prenais tellement
au sérieux que j'ai commencé à faire de
la compétition en boxe anglaise et vous
faites au premier combat je me suis pris
un cas au bout de 30 secondes
là le dernier personnage en donne par
exemple c'est le psy sérieux diplômés
etc eh ben je me suis tellement pris au
sérieux dans ce personnage là que j'ai
fini par être déprimé autant que mes
patients
donc c'est un jeu mais c'est un jeu qui
est sérieux et qui peut faire vraiment
du mal
en fait nos personnages sont nos
stratégies pour de nous donner
l'illusion qu'on est plus fort que la
vie et que surtout on est à l'abri on
est en sécurité et donc en gros grâce à
nos personnages eh ben on a l'impression
qu'on va pas souffrir on va moins
souffrir voire qu'on va pas mourir
d'ailleurs vous rendez compte que à ce
moment là si vous touchez un truc de du
personnage de quelqu'un tout de suite ça
ça pique quoi et donc il ya quelque
chose qui s'effondre au moment où on
touche à ça
donc en fait le truc c'est que au final
avec nos personnages si on les laisse
agir à notre place ben on va quand même
mourir vous êtes au courant et de on va
mourir isolés et séparés les uns des
autres sans vraiment se connaître
en fait on est en plein dans le paradoxe
humain qui est
que d'un côté on a besoin de s'affirmer
d'affirmer notre singularité et d'un
autre côté on a besoin d'appartenir à un
groupe et vous remarquerez que tous nous
conflit relationnel sont basés là dessus
comment je fais pour être moi avec
l'autre je sais pas comment est donc
moi ce que j'aimerais aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être vous partager trois idées qui
pourrait peut-être nous permettre de
créer plus de liens tout en affirmant
notre singularité
et donc ma première proposition ma
première idée c'est déjà d'arrêter de
d'essayer de vous changer
d'arrêter d'essayer de vous améliorer en
tant qu'humain vous n'êtes pas un truc
pas fini à améliorer tout la nature est
parfaite et magnifique et nous on est la
nature et on serait un truc pas infinie
qu'il faudrait améliorer c'est absurde
donc en fait l'idée c'est plutôt de se
dire ok il ya des paradoxes à gérer au
quotidien certes mais
la vie n'est pas un problème à résoudre
n'y a pas de solution à la vie nous les
humains on n'est pas un problème à
résoudre on n'est pas une équation à
résoudre
donc par exemple concrètement ça donne
quoi et ben si je me retrouve avec mes
potes 6 eh ben on va pas se retrouver un
bar et ce autopsié autour d'une bière
c'est ridicule bah oui mais tu penses
pas que ça cause de ton père que c'était
par servi
mais vous rigolez mais on fait ça tout
le temps les personnages vous les voyez
en permanence c'est pas parce que je
vais me retrouver avec mes potes
artistes que l'on va se raconter des
anecdotes en chantant des mélodies en
fait l'idée ce n'est pas de plus avoir
de personnages c'est de savoir quand on
en joue c'est de savoir quand on rentre
dans un rôle quand on en sort on
retrouve un peu de liberté et donc j'en
arrive à mon deuxième point de ma
deuxième idée c'est que peut-être qu'il
faudrait lâcher notre cv peut-être qu'il
faudrait arrêter de rentrer en relation
avec notre cv en disant tu as vu j'ai
suisses âgés et donc arrêter de se
définir pour rentrer en relation et plus
tôt peut-être simplement découvrir
laisser émerger des facettes de nous qui
émergent qui apparaissent à l'occasion
de l'autre à laquelle on la rencontre à
l'occasion de la situation
peut-être se poser la question de tient
mais qu'est ce que je vais apprendre de
moi quand je vais être avec cette
personne et vice versa moi par exemple
depuis que j'ai un fils et bat
j'apprends mon rôle de père
j'apprends mon rôle de père et donc
comme c'est un rôle et ben du coup
j'apprends des choses est en contact
avec lui et ben j'apprends que je peux
être quelqu'un de patient et de doux par
exemple alors que d'habitude j'ai pas
très patient je suis pas très tactile
non plus je pas très doux au départ mais
avec lui à l'occasion de lui à
l'occasion de notre relation il ya
quelque chose de nouveau qui émerge de
moins donc j'apprends ce rôle
et la dernière idée c'est de remettre de
la créativité dans nos relations ça
manque cruellement de créativité c'est
pour ça que les schéma se répète et
c'est pour ça que je fais chier au
quotidien
de bouc c'est vrai
pour moi je me faisais chier
peut-être pas vous est en fait la
créativité pour moi c'est retrouver
cette liberté de choisir la forme à
travers laquelle on exprime qui on a
envie d'être à chaque instant et donc
bain par exemple tu vois qu'il ya une
engueulade qui est en train de se
profiler avec ton mec outanane à tapis
sur pause et là tu te demandes et ce que
j'ai envie de jouer au con est ce que
j'ai envie de jouer au héros est ce que
j'ai envie de jouer à la victime est ce
que j'ai envie de jouer un mec qui est
reprochable sait et c'est
donc en fait
chaque relation met en lumière une
facette de nous une partie de nous le
bon comme le mauvais le beau comme le
moche l'eufor comme le fragile et en
fait peut-être que plutôt que de
chercher absolument tout le temps à
essayer de se définir et à devenir
quelqu'un par peur en fait d'être
personnes pour l'autre
peut-être qu'en fait on est tout le
temps déjà en train de devenir soi à
travers l'autre
fait finalement moi je me définis
et puis je suis merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]